thank you for your time this morning
councilors and welcome to those that
have joined us on live stream for the
this long-term plan Workshop regarding
Financial strategy and infrastructure
strategy we're actually going to take
infrastructure first so Russell
Pearson's joined us at the table welcome
Russell he's going to go through the
Financial strategy with us and we'll
take questions as we go so if you can be
there to mind
okay Russell close yours thanks Mr chip
um I think Rhiannon is would have been
here today to help us through some of
the slides but unfortunately she's not
so Patricia and I uh your
um lucky drivers for the day
Patricia has the clicker to
so I guess this is really just
leading us through
um highlighting that the financial
strategy and the infrastructure strategy
are two of the key documents that
actually do link us back to our asset
planning so I guess the
the two the two strategies are the are
the high level piece that actually sets
the I guess the overall direction and
today we're really talking about some of
those key inputs into those into those
two strategies so
and that's a it's an opportunity and a
time to say these are the sorts of
things that we are interested in in the
long term I guess that's certainly from
the infrastructure strategy perspective
it is actually looking at a 30-year
Horizon Zone
so we've um
speak a little bit we've deleted the RTP
process because that's rhiannon's um
expertise area um
I'm just going to run through what is it
what are the strategies and then what
are the key decisions for both the
infrastructure strategy and Then
followed by the financial strategies if
you think about in the process of the
ltp we've been going through a series of
workshops as we're getting through so
we've we've looked at different areas
these are the two big strategy pieces
and these are what we pull all the
documents that end up being that the
work behind the consultation document is
based off these two strategies so where
we go with our infrastructure and with
our um Financial strategies and they are
symbiotics so they do need to mesh
because we have an infrastructure
strategy that doesn't isn't supported by
a financial strategy and vice versa
it's not a great outcome
so what I thought was we just need to
reflect a little bit about the timelines
we're talking about so given around 2023
I reflect a little bit about 30 years
ago
um back in 1993 and I thought it was
actually probably a really good place to
have a little bit of a think back about
what what was going on in the city
um
and as part of that I sort of come up
with a series of actions that were going
on we had lots of pipe renewals going on
we had the we'd had the floods and we'd
got into and we were digging up the
streets and putting lots of pipes in and
about 93 we were doing lots of bridge
works as part of the flood scheme um
people recall we were building dams and
doing lots of other things
we had some work going on on Frank's
home we were putting a new clear tank
and those sorts of things
um interestingly I recall that it was
the last time we built a housing key
unit as well
um
we were planning to for Splash Palace um
Clifton wastewater treatment plant had
some improvements the library and the
car park building associated with it
were opened
we were starting about thinking about
how we were going to deal with the Civic
Theater
and I guess it's after the post 87 stock
market crash the government reforms and
the local government changes so this
really would
the purpose of the slide is to really
think back 30 years it seems like we've
now going to then go and think 30 years
ahead but a lot of those things are
still quite important key factors of our
city that
30 years on from 1993
we are here now and I guess our
opportunity is to say what is
2053 start to look like and I guess
that's really what the infrastructure
strategy is starting to form a picture
of what are those things that we would
want to do now for 2053 because I guess
if we could move back in time in 1993
would we make the same decisions we had
that were made then to put the city in
the same place we are now so I guess
that's the opportunity so next slide
thanks Patricia can ask a question
also the um
the uh Lane that says last housing Care
Unit built does that include the elderly
is that is it 30 years since we last
built one the um my recollection is that
a 1993 we finished Jim brass place in
Ellis Road it was the last housing care
unit that Council undertook the
construction off
it doesn't include maintenance
so 2053 and I guess this is the uh
I'm trying to trying to go to the end to
give you some hunts that might be what
sort of conversation so in 2050 53 what
will our city actually look like because
what we do in setup to go forward is
actually what 2053 will look like in
1993 I guess we probably thought 30
years is a long way away
um I was going to have a photo of what I
looked like in 1993. doesn't have any
gray hair then so um but I'm not sure
what I looked like in 2053 it might not
be so good either but so the sorts of
things that we might well have in 2053
we might have autonomous travel we might
actually not have people driving cars we
might have cars driving us around so
what will our roads look like what will
they do what purpose will they have
um Everybody might have a push bike or a
different means of travel so we might
have thought more about what active
transport um
the three Waters entity
may still be by others or so what will
that look like for us going forward um
if we look elsewhere in the country
there's we are bound to have had more
weather events than we've had in the
last 30 years
and what will that mean for a city will
we will we be ready for that emergency
when it does come and what form will it
take and then what will our next
decisions be around that
um what will our community spaces look
like well we actually have you know more
of places for people you know
well how will how will our city have
reacted to 30 years of use and how many
times will we've been back to actually
upgrade it refresh it to make sure it is
the place where we actually have our
business hub
how many councils will we only have one
Council by then who's to know
um and how much further private
investment will be in the city center
it's not necessarily Council but how
much private investment so yes I'm
really just sort of painting either end
of the uh the Spectrum where we're by
looking back and looking forward
in the infrastructure strategy tries to
sit those sorts of directions that it
can be implemented and put into the
asset management and the activity plans
gives us the direction of the steer of
what we're going to do and starts to
understand why we're going to do some of
those things and Patricia's side of the
world is how do we make sure we can fund
those sorts of things
question cheer for me yes yep um I think
it may have appeared in the first slide
it seems to me that one of the
absolutely critical questions I would
put my right hand side is what the
population will be here because there's
such a range of outcomes in the last 30
years populations actually almost
unchanged it's gone down and back up
again isn't it so it's pretty much the
same
it's been 30 years time climate change
might double their population
but if you believe others that make half
a population and that's a pretty big
range to be working from so I mean I I
I'm not suggesting one another tell that
I'm just saying to me that's a very
significant question you know for up
there which is actually not on that list
one of the things that I didn't have
there is what are the assumptions we
have in you you're absolutely correct
what we assume for a 30-year plan could
have some significant bearings and
population is one of those key drivers
and I guess the opportunity is for the
infrastructure strategy that there is a
regular refresh so we we won't
necessarily write an is strategy and
leave it for 30 years and drag it out
and see what we're going to do next we
get the opportunity to continue to
monitor that but some of our decisions
we make from our infrastructure teams
um are longer than 30 years so some of
them are 50 100 type years so making
making some of those decisions and
understanding what what drives our
community is key and absolutely
population our ability to pay where we
want
what sort of growth we're going to have
and where that growth occurs all fit
into the infrastructural strategy
well yeah the other question I was going
to ask was what was a rate collect in
you know to get some relevance around
cost and Revenue
what was the dollar worth
they get a chewing gum was 15 seconds
and I guess that's the relativity isn't
it
yeah no we congrat um
when we look at that that second list
are we in a position today to enter or
this just the views that are coming
forward from start
pressure we can add to it because it
could it's your views are important so
that's how Russell's gonna look into
this you know when we get to those outer
years of the both the infrastructure
strategy and the financial strategy this
all comes in sure yeah look I think it's
probably
um it's it's scene setting isn't it so
it's sort of getting air sort of Mind
thinking about some of what some of
those things would be but I wouldn't
like to think we'd spend the next half
an hour building up an exhaustive list
of all the things that should be on
there because Mr Q one of the things
infrastructure strategy does direct us
to is what's actually included within it
and it's quite the legislation is quite
clear and quite specific about the types
of assets that you have to have that
strategy to plan for so that's I was as
you say I was just sitting the scene
yeah okay did you was there something
particularly you wanted to add yeah just
a couple of three things
um one would be the the changing density
of housing yeah so we've had some
discussion about going up as opposed to
going out
um a new range of Industries coming in
the next 30 years probably some at the
front end of that and they require some
infrastructure as well certainly around
aquaculture
and the last one is the uh lack of the
council investment in South City and
Bluff
so just on that last issue it was
interesting when we went to the
presentation on Saving Grace recently
which was next door the South cities
actually decile 9 of 10 yep
um and it sits within a cluster of 200
families across the country that sit in
there and that's quite an indictment on
this city because we we tend to be at
the moment very focused on the inner
city the CBD and yet we've got on our
back door some areas that need some
investment
which will be your community spaces
thing probably yeah exactly yeah areas
areas better years to play them and
stuff like that yeah yeah right uh
thanks chair look is it's true of
infrastructure I guess my my main
concerns and I don't see them there uh
the up and coming consent requirements
for both uh Wastewater discharges at
Bluff
and for invercargill now I just haven't
seen any budgeting really for those I
know the bluff is within two years
invercargill seven years and we're
potentially looking at figures that we
actually we really don't know them and
if we go discharged to land then the
land required is quite phenomenal the
whole process Bluff on its own would
have to be re-piped somewhere
um so that's one of the that's what one
of my points do you want to talk today
so Mr chair further on into the options
that certainly is on the list of things
that need to be in their strategy and
and the conversation about those yes
because that is not hypothetical it is
real yeah well that would be covered
under three Waters into these one
because that's part of what the disaster
Land versus I think it's um there's two
elements to that it's actually the
community will need to actually matter
to to deal with it
um who actually drives that whether it
be Council or an entity I guess is a
different okay it's a different question
but it certainly is on the list of
um things and options that need to be
included in the strategy and the other
one was af8 now the Alpine fault is
there's 75 chance it will release by
2053 is the exact date they use so that
75 chance is reasonably good odds
um and if you're a council would you
look at your infrastructure and look at
the potential the risks
and the modeling around
um what what sort of effect the Alpine
fault would have here obviously it won't
be the abrasive
um chop there
closer to the um
it's like Queenstown but we will get
massive
um you know shock waves and stuff so
that I mean 75 chance it's you can't
really ignore it
and I guess that's really in 53 what I'm
saying is you know are we ready for an
emergency what does that actually mean
to our community and and with and or
whether events are the other ones that
it's highly likely that we'll have a
testing weather event within the next 30
I would be surprised if
if we miss
I mean I think we're going to end up
with quite a long list but there are
quite a number of things can happen in
the next 30 Years
um we are supposed to be Net Zero by
that time um
you know does not feature in the list
but I think should
um you know what does that mean yes I
think it's quite close to release it
actually to the emergency plan and
they're in the AFV in some respects it's
something that's a long way out but if
you don't you know have some plans in
place
so anyway
the last one was smart cities are we
evolving into a smart city and smart
city is a is like a category of city
where
um is that something we've signed up for
or are we going to do it
[Music]
with the next slide we'll actually talk
about what an infrastructure strategy is
required to actually include
so infrastructure strategy is set by The
Local Government Act and it defines what
has to be in and out and it has to be
fair as I've said it has to be for 30
years and has to deal with your renewals
and Replacements as to how you manage
growth hated public health environmental
issues
needs to include the financials for the
next 30 Years so I guess it really looks
to actually make sure there's not too
many things just hiding over the 10-year
LTB Horizon so it's
some infrastructure strategies and
across the country
run out to the whole of life so that it
can be 50 to 100 years in terms of some
of our piped or other assets
it uses the similar assumptions across
all of our plans so
um is
Tom suggested that his population is one
of those key things that will actually
drive
the strategy
the infrastructure strategy has to
include and currently only includes
water supply surge treatment and
Disposal storm water flood protection
and the provision of roads and footpaths
that's all the legislative requirements
require us to deliver in terms of our
long-term infrastructure strategy so
where we get into things like parks
houses that's not necessarily a
legislative requirement to be in the
strategy although that the asset and the
activity plans will manage those over at
least 10 and in some cases along the a
longer period where those assets
will be so for instance our properties
don't sit within the infrastructure
strategy
yep night just a couple of Reflections
here
um based on what rain you raised before
around the three Waters and Russell's
response was
um the sewage issue or the waste issue
will be a council entity issue well it
may not be either actually and so we've
got to have quite a wide brief here
before argument's sake if the hydrogen
plant gets up and running and it's
looking positive it will take all of our
waste water away so we won't have to
find a land discharge or a water
discharge because they only want potable
water which is water that's been treated
but not drinkable and the same with the
data banks that they come they need
water for cooling but again does need to
be treated water it can just be water so
and I've got people coming this week for
that Jack reason
so there are other options that we need
to have quite a wide scope as we go
forward that the solutions we're coming
towards may not be just one or two might
be quite wide
and the other issue I guess which is up
there which is the flood protector again
we don't have the final leader data yet
from environment South and when we have
that that will give us some modeling
that we can actually
in a a computerized way pour water into
the hills around South and see where the
yeah where the flooding comes out and
put more in and see where it goes
because we've tended from my perspective
to often deal with flood protection it
just means you build more more Banks and
all that does is pushes the problem
somewhere else yeah
when is that information coming soon
Steve's got his henna
sorry through your chair the the actual
data is you know only the first part of
the story there's a huge amount of
analysis it's going to be done and you
know and it's one of the things that
that climate change group that Leslie
and I sits on so on are talking about
yes at some point we will have to
discuss who pays for that
[Music]
um and you know to the extent to which
that's paid by environment South London
the extent to which it's paid by the
city
um if it's paid by environment Southland
we might come eighth on the list or
something because a lot of concern about
going with Tara and so on so we
um you know the the it's I think all of
the all of the flying has been done
actually and the data is just to be
ready to be launched but it will just be
a series of doubts and numbers it's not
going to tell us anything until the
analysis is done so but I mean that's
all doable within a year so I think
within a year we ought to have the the
data that allows us to make the account
of decisions yeah do you agree a little
yeah
it's not a significant activity of this
Council no we we manage one piece of
flood Banks being the new stop Bank
along stead Street and Cobb Road which
we've upgraded to a higher standard so
in terms of an infrastructure strategy
in terms of that 30 plus year Horizon
um I guess air exposure to change or
risk in that space would be relatively
be seen to be relatively low and
um and we should have a degree of
comfort that it's
um at least strong enough at the moment
whether it's high enough will be climate
change yeah I mean the the thing though
is
and it's a bit to Thomas point where you
know if invercargill cities are low
priority because you know they focus on
the material catchment for example we've
still got citizens that need protected
so we we can't just sort of leave it can
we we've got to use that data to inform
us and we might have to pull some of
that work for ourselves
I guess one of the things about the data
which Tom talks about is it does allow
us to model uh rainfall at different
levels yes absolutely like pouring water
you put one cup into the system and see
what happens put two cups in so the
beauty of that is it forces you to think
outside the square yeah so a good
example is as Gore recently flooded in
recent times
um they're now looking at hey we might
burst a stock Bank before goal as the
water comes down and let it run onto
Farmland as opposed to running into
residential area so a whole lots of new
thinking around some of the stuff
and and how you protect certain key
assets like airports and things like
that yeah Ria you hit gnw I just um
Russell was looking at the provision of
roads and put parts and wondered in your
um era of expertise do you foresee
infrastructure placement locations
changing from out of the road into
footpaths for instance and being able to
look at that future of smart cities
um
the Road Corridor was used for many
things and how we use them over the
whether it's a smart city or a transport
it's going to be what is it going to
what we want it to do
but I don't think we're going to get
transformational change in terms of our
whole Road Corridor in 30 years
um I think we will struggle to change a
lot of our
way we use our networks over that over
the next 30 Years I don't think we're
going to see and we're not necessarily
predicting or seeking funding to
actually change our road Network
significantly over that period because
we've got
know everybody says we've got nice big
wide roads how do we allocate them I
think the challenge is that Council
might face is how do you use them in
different sense it may well be that in
time there may well be considerational
requests to remove parking and have
better cycle Lanes on roads
sure that's not necessarily A an easy
topic to deal with but it actually is if
you want to change the way you use your
community then it may well be some of
the things that you need to do to
actually get
solution so not sure I've answered your
question fully
but I think
roads and footpaths are going to be one
of the things that
will remain with Council
and it will be something that will
become part of a core
infrastructure about how do we manage
those and how we how do we use them for
the greatest benefit for a community
going forward
okay
well sorry
so
buttons actually between invercargill
and Bluff
when we're going to start talking about
that seriously
you're talking about the road I know
Russell's answer I could just about
repeat it it's a Waka kotahi issue but
it's also our issue because
stuff is part of the cargo so how are we
going to advance that discussion
totally agree and I think there's a
series there's a series of steps there
and I know that makakatahi have sought
some funding in the short term to raise
some of those low-lying areas of the
State Highway
which would be a significant Improvement
um anywhere we've only got a single
point of access whether it be for a
pipeline or a or a road you have a
vulnerability that if that's closed you
are cut off for the period of time until
you can re-establish it
um certainly with climate change
impacting those things over a longer
period of Time air access to Bluff will
be a prime consideration for both
Council and wakakotei but I'm more
optimistic now that they've actually
have some funding in the pipeline to
actually be able to improve that in the
short term because there are sections of
the road that do it um
get consumed by water and high tide such
really is quite a
unacceptable outcome for a state highway
I would I would have thought
we will have roads that will be but we
are relatively fortunate that we aren't
necessarily as dependent on the
coastline directly there'll be some of
the Melissa used roads but our grid
networks and how we manage certainly
around um Bond Street and those
industrial areas how we mitigate that
for a period of time will be a question
because if we allow it lower than the
water we'll have to keep the water out
yeah I just have a point that this was
sort of raised at the butt Community
College
and one of the things that we were
actually hoping for was to have time
nice
in regards to the The Works being done
because that's one thing that's
invisible is that
there is no timeline around the pieces
of work that's required on that road
Mr one of the things that we continue to
work closely with wakatai is is that we
don't fund work on the state highway
um I'm absolutely certain that if we
wish to to fund the work and do it that
they would jump up and down but there's
no reason there's no logical reason why
we would take over their responsibility
where it is a responsibility I guess our
role as a whole of council will be to
continue to advocate for them in the
importance of what that
lifelines the connection to the
community will be and we shouldn't and
we should continue to push that case as
strong as we can so that we get the
right
share of money at the right time to to
protect
area our access to our communities
okay
okay so then we'll jump on to what the
finance strategy is
um so again it's legally required and it
identifies our approach to prudent
financial management of funding and
expenditure
so there's some key assumptions that
underpinnednesses do underpin the whole
of the ltp which is their population
changes but also our land use changes
which is much to what the mayor has said
earlier this morning
um and the capex and Optics associated
with how we may respond to those changes
um
sits at that capital expenditure on
those core infrastructure
um so that's why the financial strategy
matches the infrastructure strategy with
a minimum of 30 years
um we also include the some key
decisions that sit in that which
includes limits on rates increases and
debt and also rates affordability
but also sets the policies in relation
to borrowing and investment so those are
the core bits legislatively that we have
in the financial strategy
um in relation to investment we're
meeting those key measures that we may
have in relation to our investments in
invercargill City Holdings Group
um and the levels of return that we'll
be looking on in Investments
and we'll discuss that as we get on
it is any questions
just a reflection on that um I don't see
this as an area of significant change
for us historically we've done very well
when I compare with our otago South and
colleagues and then some in the
Canterbury District we're in a much much
better fiscal position than they are and
that's not just by choice
it's because we've managed well in the
past so we maintain what we've done in
the past I think we'll be in a good
position in the future
Tom
uh I know I have asked this question
before uh I'm interested in if the
thinking's moved on at all
um but f is a consequence of three
Waters or some other version of that in
the future
um you know billion dollars worth of
assets come out of birdheins and at the
hands of somebody else so that we are
borrowing in a much lower asset base how
is that going to affect our ability to
borrow
doesn't affect their ability to borrow
because with via lgfa our borrowing is
based off our income
so it's not the losing of the asset
value it's the losing of the collection
of water rates that becomes an issue and
that's something that we were going to
be busy modeling very shortly okay thank
you
I think it is a sense what what how much
of that would it be a 30 impact on right
time yeah
across the city roughly 30
um off the top of my head but that's
because not everybody has water or
sewage so in some parts people's you
know it's if you think about it from a
rate payer they'll pay what they pay us
will be split between us and a water in
today if that goes ahead but they might
be paying more to the water until
they're going forward so sorry I can ask
her yeah because I I thought I
understood the answer then
go home confused it for me
um so are you seeing then as a
consequences that are just rates take it
will actually reduce their ability
borrow by about 30 and does that flow
through to the ability of whole Curry
bottle
no okay so it's limited to the city
limited to the councils because in the
way the council Security on their debt
works it works off our ability to rate
okay okay and whole course bordering is
based on data set basis is that the
our borrowing is based on the uncle
capital
and what you've got at the moment is a
situation where Council recognizes the
risk to council from that uncalled
Capital so for those that aren't aware
uncall capitals basically shares that we
have issued to council but that I
haven't been paid and so in the event
that the holding company required funds
or became insolvent the Liquidator and
the ordinary course would walk in and
say to council you need to pay for those
shares
so Council records that is a contingent
liability on their books at the moment
but our borrowing is not a function of
our revenue or our assets as much as
there are some conditions around our
borrowing that relate to our revenue and
our assets
fundamentally it always falls back to
being capped at the uncalled Capital
issue to council but does that then mean
the the council's ability to satisfy
this uncalled Capital which we're tough
to do sort of modeling presumably is
going to be reduced as a consequence of
three Waters or something like that and
therefore the ability to it won't then
call Capital fall
as a consequence of that it doesn't have
to it counts as I said Council needs to
and we've been doing this for the last
few years needs to make an assessment as
to the realistic Prospect of that
occurring and therefore the allowance it
makes for that contingent liability at
the moment Council has got a very
conservative position where effectively
the entire uncalled capital is taken
away from your borrowing but that in
essence is an assumption that you've got
100 likelihood so it can be risk
adjusted it could be responsive yeah but
there there is some materiality to an
impact
um yeah just touching on the three water
modeling now
can someone explain so it's we've got 14
million in three water dead Queenstown
Lakes district has 160. and three water
debt Janine's got
a massive amount as well you put that
all together say for entity
JK whatever it is
um we all in split it up and we pay we
pay
a share of that combined it now
obviously does that that is no longer a
debt for Council that is a debt of the
entity and so we don't have
to worry about that the entity would
Bill the rate payer or as a bill Council
or how does that all work how do how
does the how does the end result
come
discounts or wash its hands completely
of if the entity goes ahead
they're very good questions no I can
probably help with that Grant yeah um
the feedback with from DIA around the
entities is that uh ring is quite right
the debt goes we will get a
proportionate prorator per capita cost
going after each rate payer and the
entity so it'll be the same regardless
of where you live
um so we will we will cross subsidize
but in the interim and Michael can tell
me if I got this wrong but certainly the
Dio said that in the interim Council
will collect the rates
so we will physically collect the rates
um the risk I guess for that is that as
the rates escalate up and they will
escalate out quite quickly for us we'll
be seen to be the the problem that's
pushed the rates up in fact we're not
yeah so what I'm getting at currently we
pay about 860.
per person per household that's going to
easily escalate if you look at the
figures I just gave you to three
thousand per household just like that
just like that all of a sudden and the
rates will come from us will be perhaps
on an ICC letterhead maybe unless we can
be clever and not have that
um so just looking that's really
um at the end of the day when we look at
all our Ford Pike
forecasts and stuff like that
really when this hits
it's just going to blow everything else
else out of the water and make roading
and all our other stuff seem
insignificant to currently what we pay
in water rates on three water rates
so yeah yeah we we have no say
s
but if we take it back to what the
purpose of the ltp oh is here that yes
we've I think you've got a slow coming
up haven't you wrestle around um three
Waters yes that's those are issues that
we're going to have to deal with
operationally in the short term we need
to be sort of focused for this session
on the more longer term
um
rather than those are issues let's deal
with some strategic
um bits going forward
just wanted to clarify what Patricia
said before about the uh the loss of the
loss of the asset or the value of the
asset as opposed to the loss of the
revenue that comes from that asset which
is the three water gases versus the
rateable for the three Waters so if
we've got roughly a 30 drop off
we've got some degree of
disproportionate impact there because I
suspect that most of our borrowing is
not to do with three Waters at the
moment that's to do with depreciation
um and so what we're borrowing for are
things like involvement the ICL Museum
whatever so
in some ways we're going to get a bit of
an imbalance here aren't we there is a
bit of an imbalance and that's where the
strategy becomes more important and some
of the mob like that'll be shared with
you later sure and the year will become
important as we'd look to see what it
looks like on a rebalanced we will be
doing both scenarios sure
um just to calibrate the numbers a
little bit though um because I may be
completely wrong in this but as I
understand it it's not quite true to say
that we inherit the debt but we inherit
the interest in our shared of the day
don't we so we we would have to appear
to share that interest on the day so so
let's suppose their share of Interest
was 100 million just for argument's sake
um and that hundred million was you know
five percent interest that's five
million dollars a year divided by 30 000
houses which is like 150 bucks my math
is correct so it's north thousands
and I'm not saying it's good to 150 is a
lot of money for some people but but you
know just to calibrate it I mean I might
be completely wrong without my armor you
are no no I mean you're way wrong yeah
but hey because that's okay
Dia advice is that
um auckland's current writer would write
to about 800 and 10 years from now will
be 800.
and our rates are as ranking said about
800 and something by year 10 it'll be up
around the 2000 some suggest three
thousand but I've seen things around 2
200. so up
200 and something percent in 10 years
so it is significant
and to me it's because of the need to
invest that's one issue which is a the
global picture of the 180 billion
they're talking about over 30 years but
the other issue is we will cross
subsidize other councils that are not in
such a good position for us so we will
not be we will not be uh
um
servicing out data 14 million will be
servicing a whole lot more yeah there's
a terrible pump but there's a lot of
water to go under the bridge
Russell we do have this every day in
October
so now we just want to run through I
guess this the three three big chunks of
the infrastructural strategy which is
um the key of what today is really about
and the first part is about how do we
confirm our approach to network
management and when we talk about
Network management remember we're
talking about stormwater surge
water
flood protection and Roads that's what
we're dealing with so Patricia so we've
got that plus we've got we're going to
I'd like to talk a little bit about our
approach to what the three Waters
direction will be and then the last
section is about what are some of the
key decisions and that's
um that we will need to make sure that
the strategy helped directs us and I
guess this is where it helped directs
our technical people to make sure we're
approaching this in the right way so
that's really what today is about isn't
it are we dealing with this at the right
strategic Direction rather than some of
that detail so
so what I've tried to do a little bit is
um
hopefully is to actually
have some different colors so in the
next slide I think there's some so
really what I'm trying to look for here
is about
um a fundamental approach to our
networks uh that
our high level
position is that we continue to maintain
our
maintain our acid base so we're not
necessarily looking to to grow our
services out in a wider context across
across our city boundaries
whether that be the right strategy or
not but that does mean that we're not
necessarily racing out there to increase
where we deliver sewage to where we
deliver water to because we do have
areas where we have within our district
plan and other documents where we
service and we which places some
opportunity in
um
I guess the extra uh
problems for people to subdivide some of
those areas so I guess it's about us
maintaining what we've currently got
we're not
we've talked about this morning we
haven't got a population that's growing
so why do we need a bigger Network and
networks were sized in the 70s for a
potentially uh guess bigger population
than we've currently got so we've been
been fortunate for the last 20 plus
years of my view that we've been able to
consume some of that extra capacity and
therefore we haven't had to do what many
of the growing cities have as soon as
you put the pipe in you've got to start
planning for the next one but it's not
going to be big enough so
um
a growth forecasts and their population
will be part of that driver so our
assumption is that we will only maintain
what we've really got
that's not necessarily A
hard-coded but it is really a quarter
action so if we want to do something
elsewhere somewhere else then that's the
direction we're looking at that level
for instance if we want to supply water
to perhaps a community but let's just
say perhaps odatara for no other reason
for than a conversation is then at the
moment air plan isn't to do that
but if that's what the council sees as
our future Direction then we would need
to incorporate that into our into our
future strategy so that we could produce
a cost model
so that's the that's the
biggest basis of of that so at the
moment we have limitations in some parts
of our community where the landlords are
big enough to service sewage disposal so
in those places you can't subdivide
sections we've got limitations about
where we've got different District plan
zones and I guess
this is the overlap between where we
have services and where we have a
spatial plan with our planning
colleagues about where we want the city
to grow in if we want the city to grow
in that's so that's a really key
um element of our thinking going forward
about how we deliver us our
infrastructure services
my road
water supply
when are we going to look at building
the reservoir year to safely deliver
water to the places on Tramway Road that
currently don't receive water supply and
I won I wonder if that
um
is
going to be either pressured one way or
another by what happens with the poor
White because some of it is going to be
supplied from existing something but
when you come up to my road that will
not be possible what's going to happen
then
and I guess a water a water model will
actually show where we can and can't
deliver to and I guess that's part of
what we have in the district plan we is
we have a zone that says there's a red
hard coat of land that's pieces of land
that says if you're inside here we will
deliver water to you if you're outside
there you don't get water supply just
the same as we have for other areas
where we've got zones that said you get
storage Supply in there and are rated
for them
other areas
I think the solution for The Wider issue
in terms of water supply is closely
linked with the alternative water supply
and and where that fits as a priority
for
um
the council and then and or if it's
whatever future delivery mechanism the
reservoir water
because at the moment
we have
um
a number of ring Mains that go around
the city that we have reasonable Supply
but you are correct there has always
been a long-term Vision to have a
further Reservoir down in Skies the sky
Street area to actually supplement
storage and delivery but
but that's what the long-term
future asset plan would deliver through
the alternative water supply
nothing
um yeah the third area that you've got
there Russell's probably the most
important for me which is a focus on the
asset critical criticality
um so regardless of which way the
election goes if we were going to
assumption that Labor uh get past the
next election we have the water entities
why would we do anything in the period
up to 2026 unless it was critical
now some councils have gone the other
way they've they've known that three
water entities were coming have jumped
in and done massive amounts of um
infrastructure upgrades on the
assumption that they would not be a
priority
when the entities kick in so Queen
sounds a good example of that they've
got growth but they've been doing a lot
of investment in their actual stock at
the moment which is right in the middle
of Queensland every second Street's been
ripped up at the moment
I'm the same for Dunedin they knew that
South city was probably not going to be
a priority even though it's got a
climate change
a leans over it
um so they've done a lot of work there
as well so they've got in on the
assumption that they'll have some
short-term pain on their rates because
you have to service the debt but it'll
eventually go away to the entity we've
got the actual reverse of that so what
we've got is why would we jump in the
2024 which is an option for us with the
otago south of cluster and our rate
payers would then be subject to higher
water rates because that'll definitely
happen the moment we jump into bed
um we're in fact if we listen to Brad
Olson who tells us that the current cost
of living pressures on families is
likely to lessen in the next 18 to 24
months so up until about 20 25 26 we get
some relief then if we then jumped in
with the tiger South and at the latter
part of that which is 2026. we're
keeping the pressure off our ratepayers
in the interim now the downside of going
in late is that we've become very
unpopular I mean I've already I've
already said to some of my colleagues
that win that we're not keen on jumping
until we know what the election delivers
us but I think we'd be mad to jump in
early anyway but most of the other big
players on a tiger's album want the
early entity because I get rid of the
deep but you've got to ask the question
why do they want to get rid of the dev
and that's because they're struggling to
service it and therefore we're all
subsidize that so I guess to me that's
the real hard question in there
um certainly my view would be that we
hold out till closer to 2026 because
that gives our rate payers some relief
um
hadn't we already resolved that nobody
else that we had already decided as a
council that we would hold off we have
but but our hold off was really to we
knew where the landscape was election
wise and so post-election we will need
to reinforce it because I think under
any model that we go into the Target
South and we cross subsidize the other I
mean Michael will tell you that we're in
the best financial position on three
Waters of all the councils in otago
Falcon so the only benefit that comes of
economy of scale for US is is there will
be economy of scale for some but all
they're doing is just taking the
existing debt and spreading it a bit
thinner and so there are benefits for
Queenstown and Dunedin in particular
disadvantage for us disadvantage for
Central otago that's got water meters
the Russell Mr chair if I could just run
through the rest of those and sorry I'd
like to I'd like to come back to that
question because it raises a really
really really key
um because the points I've got up there
are about how we focus on how we develop
our plans and those plans deliver the
future Direction which includes your
budgets going forwards the ltp is
actually based around coming up with a
long plan so this is how this is how we
address our asset development of our
plan so this is their core fundamental
so and if I could just run through them
quickly then we can have that question
about criticality so
the basis of air presumption is that we
actually renew our assets at the rate of
consumption so that is where the
financial strategy sits across it so if
we actually we have enough money to
renew
on the life cycle so in the past we've
actually
and historically we have struggled
we sorry we haven't renewed as fast as
we've been consuming so we do actually
have in some of those situations shorter
times and no money in the bank I suppose
but that's where our learned Financial
colleagues have a magic wand to fix
those things for us
um focus on criticality and I guess what
we're really saying is that some of our
pipes and our networks are really
important so for instance our bank sign
pipelines that bring the water from
bankstown to our reservoirs are really
key to us so if there was a problem with
those we would focus our works programs
and I guess that's the level we're
talking about to those whereas some of
our other streets where we've got less
problems or less consumers sitting off
them we might
have a level of service on our delivery
or our renewals we might take more risks
on some of those other areas and on on
some of their key things and we've been
doing that
for a period of time and you'll have
seen some of the bigger renewal programs
that we've brought forward
we need to make sure it is based on SC
now we've got to have some good decision
making because otherwise we just don't
want to randomly get out there and pick
what we're doing
by a specific number
we do need to actually look at our
pipeline designs to deal with certainly
in our stormwater about climate change
and what that will bring and I guess the
lidar data helps us as a data source
but what we designed for going forward
is is the issue we've seen issues like
in Auckland where they had rainfall
events which isn't you know it's a
rainfall event not a flood
but it results in something and it
results on whether water will flow and
that's something that we don't currently
model and we will we will with the lidar
that's the next thing but to model I
guess that is one of the things that we
will be putting up for consideration to
do the modeling we have to fund it it's
not a cheap exercise but to understand
some of these things going forward and
make use of that data you need to commit
into some of those projects to be able
to get the right result
yeah and against the understanding
Community is is one of those key
assumptions you know where is where is
their City moving what is it doing
what's their population where is the you
know where is the growth that we need to
to match and that's really key to all of
our core infrastructure
and the bottom one is to strengthen our
asset management
this like
the smarter we actually have a team
in-house actually the better the
solutions
oh my guess and that's a challenge for
all local government about how you keep
train and and your in-house teams are
experienced in your networks and
actually I guess treat them with the
stewardship that we need to carry or
carry on with so
the other fundamentals of our
um
Asset Management plans and that's how we
form our
future budgets and our future programs
from those so if if any time you ask us
you see someone coming up and we build
we're going to do something you should
be able to identify those things that
are driving our decisions to be on the
tables
Tom
in my experience depreciation rates
usually take a fairly conservative view
of the leaf team of an asset and the
whole point of the bottom Dash Point
near strength and asset management is
that we seek to make the assets last
longer using modern techniques that we
that we have now last longer than the
rate than the age assumed depreciation
may assume some last 10 years you make
it less 15 if you're smart and how you
maintain it and and I can't achieved
from what you said there wrestler that's
what you are talking about
um I I guess all I'm seen as a you know
reinforcing that that's absolutely what
everybody does know so I mean I don't
know that anybody replaces a
depreciation rate anymore because it's
because we modern asset management
techniques you actually don't have to
get smart enough
part of our evaluation process in our
renewal process is to actually establish
what we believe are
realistic
asset lives and we continue to push
those at to raise me long lives they're
not short lives like for instance our
footpaths we have footpaths that we're
planning not to replace
um
between 65 and 80 years for a concrete
footpath so that's not a short life at
all so we know that our road surfacing
we have 18 years or thereabouts between
reseals which is probably one of the
longest
recite return periods for most councils
so
be assured that our finance colleagues
have made sure that we uh we don't have
two shorter lives but you start to see
that in the um the the depreciation
which is a which is a an assessment of
um consumption and I guess that's the
um
the mix between the two is how close how
close to that number are you because
anyone here you won't but in over any 10
years you should be getting to it
because
um we wouldn't want to find a situation
like Wellington and other councils are
where they have probably pushed a little
bit hard and you start to see the
consequence
um you know hopefully their pipes that
are bursting aren't the critical ones if
they are then they've got it completely
wrong
a couple things about that um
like you wouldn't want to stop doing
renewals for the next two years
um I mean you could and just just
respond to failures because in my lay
terms I think it does make much
difference whether you dig a street up
to replace it because it's got the
75-year time frame or whether you dig it
up because it's spewing water into the
street it's still the same cost in it
and it's probably the same time trying
to fix it but the trouble is if you
don't do a regular pattern of
Maintenance and you stall it for a few
years and do a whole lot less when you
do need to uptake the people that are
potentially going to do it have gone
and they're no longer there anymore
they've drifted off to work elsewhere
and then you don't have the capacity to
expand so um so that's one issue in the
other issue which seems to be missing
for me here I was touched on by some of
the others before was the issue of um
water heading towards Bluff so we got
the caller student announcing in the
last couple of days a big industrial
park there we've got hydrogen down there
and we've got a significantly for fresh
water for salmon farms and certainly the
aquacultures are sitting in and around
the freezing weeks so I understand
Russell you confirm otherwise that our
current capacity to get water down the
bluff is at its peak and so whether our
alternative water supply needs to kick
in and direct some water that way but
it'll it'll require some infrastructure
as well
you're correct we will need if we have
significant development towards Bluff
then we we will need to ensure that we
have more ability to deliver to Bluff
um but once again I guess that's that's
that quandary of the who pays if it's a
development is it a
um you know an OverWatch period so
as long as we understand how we can
deliver it and when and what the lead
times are are the key issues there and
the alternative water supply and how you
might manage and deliver that and what
that might mean will be part of a wider
picture but
um we have
enough water supply generally to satisfy
what we're currently doing if we have
growth in some of those areas as part of
that growth strategy then you need to be
able to deliver the solution perhaps
just jump to the next slide it's
probably it's probably not ranging did
you have a question related oh look it
was purely about the comment about
concrete footpaths lasting 70 years like
I run every morning and seriously the
concrete because they're done sections
you don't have a you know because
obviously they pour it and then they
pour the next bit it's just a disaster
seriously you'll
right round where I run it's just the
concrete that's why I run on the road is
that the con they're either subsiding so
they don't align the two blocks or they
they start crumbling and cracking so I
don't know I just the 75-year comment
really sort of gets into me away but
that that I'm not seeing it I'm not
seeing it at all
uh in theory maybe but in practice
absolutely not
so that's just a yeah sort of had to
Chuck that one in
thanks Forrest
Russ
or just just a quick reflection on what
Russell just said about signaling the
future of who would provide I think
that's really important because
um some Ministries will will not come
here unless they say no they've got
security around water just as they want
the same security around energy as well
um now no if you talk to the hydrogen
people
um
Woodside are quite open to helping with
that development of the infrastructure
they're open to that
um but other players like the salmon
Farms maybe working on assumption
that'll just be available
and if we suddenly change the landscape
so well you know there's got to be some
sort of joint venture to bring it down
everything's available for a price yeah
that that becomes an issue if we want
economic to harm
us so this was really about is is really
about the three Waters about so from a
from a an asset management perspective
in the infrastructure's perspective
um as the affordable Waters
becomes clearer about what's
going on we have to consider how we we
have asset plans or or how do we
actually present information that will
be able to be fed into the long-term
plan which will actually be acceptable
through the the audit process
and this is really just giving you a
heads up about um
there's a two there's two two options
that we're currently being proposed that
we can
proceed on and do our own
Asset Management plans for the 30-year
period as we would have normally done
and
developer the next 30 years of what we
think needs to happen or the NTU have
suggested that they will have a more
generic plan later after Christmas that
will actually have our
first shed first two years and the key
element here and I think this is where
[Music]
is really quite important to us is that
we have
we are of the understanding The Entity J
which is the entity we will be planned
to be part of will take the program
which we propose for years one and two
and put that into the program
so years three to ten will be in terms
of the interviews program so whatever
Council decides to do in years one and
two will be what goes on so that's 24.25
and then for year three will be that
um and the last statement is the problem
with the piece that's there is that the
NTU looks for significant decisions but
they've also used a term that I thought
was interesting is no gaming
um what does no gaming actually mean um
but what that actually says is that
councils all councils will have
different priorities for different
projects so if we had three projects
that currently are on our box and they
could be for anything
um
and we would as officers would bring
them to the council when the council
would decide to put them in order and
which one she would do
um
how you strategically decide which one
you want to do could actually be
dependent on whether or not the new
entity would actually see the same
priority as you do in two years time so
you may well think well I'll do project
three I won't do project three for two
years because they have to do it in two
years time and I'll get it anyway and
I'll do I'll commit to years one and two
and then they'll be forced them to do
three so thinking about how all those
things actually play out is I think what
the gaming the bigger game picture is
but things like our alternative water
supply about where it's planned and
programmed May well be a priority for
this Council
but it may not always be the same
priority after year two for the new
entity so it could well be that they see
other development elsewhere in their
entity as having a higher priority after
year two so
when you when you start when you commit
in terms of the ltp process can have
some really key long-term opportunities
or strategic issues for the long long
term Community by making sure what you
do so
um yeah just want to support Russell's
comments there because when nobody and I
were in Dunedin listening to the DIA
uh do the bed on three water at question
time we asked the DIA about 30-year
plans and stuff like these for the
entities
and he said no way would they have
30-year plans they'll be lucky to have
three-year plans but would be from the
impression I got would just be fighting
fires
um just that'd be I mean fighting prizes
and going to the highest priorities and
working down the list
and Russell's absolutely right that
there would be no structure that we
could visibly see
to to us this new entity I know that the
um a range of officers across councils
have been working pretty to to form a
10-year Financial forecast for the new
entity and
um and that's
to certain degree a relatively
unconstrained budget is what they were
looking for so that sort of puts lots of
things on the table so that they can
then see them in in the whole entity as
a as a whole and then prioritize now
um who prioritizes those will be the
challenge of course this is probably
good news rather because the DIA it
didn't really have a clue
in terms of when we commit to the
alternative water supply and personally
I see it's a high priority for the for
the city very high priority but at the
moment it's not been held up by Council
not making a decision it's been held up
with a fight that has technical work to
be done that we had to build last month
and you know that was good to be done in
good order before it can be brought
forward so
it is that start within two years
actually a realistic proposition even if
we wish to Russell given the technical
work given the requirement then to get
you know payments and what true
environment so it's Miss humble into a
whole lot I mean as even feasible to
even think about two years
Mr chair I'm not necessarily the expert
in this field but I think we would want
to make sure that we would be as
advanced and as far committed as we
could be if that's the council's desire
to be in terms of its priority
no exactly just to reinforce what the
ring he said
um the structure with the entity
regardless of which entity it is at the
decision on priorities is not made by
those that have votes on The Entity
so it's it's not um it's not the 75
significance provision which councils
and Evie can vote on it's actually with
the board that's appointed to the entity
that make the decision that I can tell
you when I threw up the alternative
water supply and said look we don't have
one we're one of the few cities that
doesn't have one so we're at risk
um and what do you need the water for
the debate I got thrown back at me was
well yeah population's been static for a
decades as Tom quite Riley says
um you're talking about water which will
May predominantly be for industry and
for economic development with some
Pockets elsewhere and on the other side
of the equation you've got cell one
jumping from 7 000 population to seventy
thousand and eight years and Queenstown
going the same way as well and South
Dunedin having climate change stuff we
will be way down the list
and that that's a dilemma for us
um
that unless we can signal early and make
it a high very very high priority and
maybe our only priority will be left
behind
yeah the sense it feels like that is the
key thing we need to get and it really
is almost ASAP isn't it is that
alternative water source be it for just
a contingency or for economic growth
so I think that's probably what I'm
picking up
here's the last section that will assist
me completing my infrastructure strategy
is about what are the key decisions that
we actually are looking for from from
Council so
Patricia will look to cover off how do
we actually our asset life for
consumption that's the funding issue are
we actually looking to
um
do as much renewal workers we actually
consume
um the climate change we're really
looking to just give be comfortable with
that we continue to have a the mid-range
forecasters which is what we've been
using in terms of the neighbor's
neighbor information so that seems to be
a reasonably consistent approach that's
being taken by the councils
I think making sure we're really clear
about what our city center renewals
you know places you know
where does that fit in the in the
timeline and I think
we're currently developing a paper that
will
appear at the finance and projects that
will help to give some direction in
there
some of the other bigger projects that
will
or have some options on infrastructure
strategies what are we going to do it's
still important we've headed it on the
box as a I guess as a community issue
but haven't necessarily been able to
um identify a feasible and sustainable
option for the really the car parking
issue at the and we'll put a range of
options in for Stirling point
we'll have there some conversations
about opportunities for Suburban places
and I guess that's where
um
how do we refresh Bluffs yesterday
Windsor those sorts of areas which are
outside our city center
which have had some form of urban
Rejuvenation 20 plus years ago
what are we going to do with them in the
next 30 Years is that something we just
have to reinvest as a renewal
do we do we actually wish to look at
some of the other areas of infill around
our district where we've got I guess
some growth and also some of those land
development areas which have been infill
but there's still areas to go which we
currently can't
easily service will be allow growth to
actually give the district plan some
extra guidance about where we want to do
do we want to put other drains or water
supply or footpaths or street lights
into some of those areas where perhaps
they're now much more urban than they
have historically been certainly in the
next 30 Years
and I guess that's the bottom one is you
know
what do we foresee as some of the
strengths for urban trends like in
places like otatara
there's a couple on the other page we'll
just just I'll put I'll put them all out
we've got into some of the um the purple
ones which are you know the discharge
consents and we need to put up some
options and Council of ponder is
absolutely correct that the Clifton and
Bluff discharge options are pretty key
decisions in terms of infrastructure
strategy for us for now we'll have two
years of influence and then we won't
have any influence but certainly in the
period of the next 10 years those are
relatively significant costs
um to to our community delivered by
somebody it doesn't matter who it is but
there are alternatives that we need to
continue to to watch but uh at the
moment um
one of the thoughts may be a need to
discharge to land is a is a
could well be a future consent condition
if we don't have other options
there's some further works on the
resilience and we don't see apart
networks we've got some of those big
pipes that we talked about the
criticality that are sitting a little
bit over the next 10 years but perhaps
they might need to be pulled closer to
one or two to make sure they're in our
mids but we shouldn't hide from the
criticality of some of our pumped sewer
Mains that are aging they are singular
pipes that we are very reliant on for
instance mersey streets are a relatively
large pumped main that takes
nearly 40 plus percent of the city to
Clifton um
blind on that pipe and that's the only
one we've got so how we have a how we
have some redundancy being built into
their forward planning if we were
looking after this for the whole life
you would see that on our program really
early
but but once again editara Linda's farm
and Russell Street are some of our key
Rising Mains that are singular
um
part of our infrastructure is that how
do we make sure we've got contractors
and funding with enough long-term
signals so they can skill up to deliver
it
lucky but last on my list was a water
tower that we've um
had many a debate on but it's uh their
own strengths and manage it is a part of
our core infrastructure at the moment
and we'll need to transfer that so happy
to have a discussion on those topics but
I see those as a key
issues that we will have will bring back
in our infrastructure strategy is
setting your direction
um it was in the previous page but
actually applies to
several of those I think when we when we
think about um can we go to the previous
page
I think when we think about things like
asset life assumption
um the the key to be for Council is
really a bit risk appetite isn't it you
know what appetite do we have for bus
pipes or for you know any other
breakdown are we prepared to take the
risk of breakdown and and I think the
the having had that debate
um Council of Yuna I think then feeds
into officers so in that case that means
we have to assume this asset life
conditions so I I I what I was
responding to I guess was thinking about
how enough would a counsel other than us
having different views lately since 20
years I see 25 30 basis
um it really is a bit risk apathy I
think that's where the you know I think
that's where you get the rich
conversation
are we
um yeah just a couple of things for me
um
I guess this is a lot of work we do at
the moment it's built on the assumption
that we'll be in an entity at the end of
the day and and we shouldn't just be uh
planning for that because we could
potentially with a change of government
not be in any entity just stand alone so
we need to be mindful of that whatever
decisions we make may leave us with
Council doing business as usual
um some other way of funding some of the
work
um
the other issue that's not there is is
how we structure our district plans
because we've got some restrictions
around the district playing about where
things can and can't be
and that includes certain areas that you
can and can't build in or subdividing or
areas where we might want to intensify
housing and it's interesting when you
can see that we've got a static
population that we still have a growth
of new builds that people want to live
in better suburbs and I think part of
that is because if you leave your
housing portfolio static you get a
deterioration at the bottom end so I
guess part of our stock is getting to a
stage where it's not all that good so
you end up with one or two scenarios
somebody comes in and buys an old
of a bloody place I guess and
flattened it and build something new but
they're still burning it in a street
that doesn't look all that good or
whether you go off to a subdivision and
try and build 20 or 30 houses that might
look pretty sharp
um and so the other issue you had up
there was the issue he mentioned about
avatara and heartsing services look like
I mean as you know I eliminate a tower
um and I'm not connected to sewerage or
water why would we spend any uh why
would it be a key decision to put water
into even though there's 1500 houses
which is quite substantial because the
status quo is actually okay
really is I mean they like that fresh
water because sometimes yeah tap water
runs out but it's not the end of the
world there's a lot of other priorities
we've got beyond that
I would have thought even
yeah just so that I have a clearer
understanding
of what the other impacts of infill
housing is so obviously there's there's
water and sewage
but that would also include
um
electrical
services and perhaps a little bit more
lighting perhaps or a change to
um
uh roading and Grace and egress things
like that are there any other things
that we should be looking at
infrastructure is what if we do go down
the infill housing
um intensification it's typically your
ability to actually dispose of your
sewage you know normally your water is
relatively straightforward to deliver
and rodent we've got lots of capacity
Road Network to be able to accommodate
more cars or bikes and people walking
and buses
ring uh just
um replying to knobby's comments about
odatara
and I'm quite happy with with that sort
of comment but unfortunately we're
getting requests from people wanting to
Subs divide sections in outer Tara that
have already Town Supply on them and
they're only designed for room of one
house and they want to put a ape in that
large section now the pipe system out
there is is only was only ever designed
for a minimal amount
and so people are wanting and and are
wondering why we're not we're not
letting them go ahead so this is where
Russell's coming from he's looking to
the Future well there's people asking
for for these increased services so we
can just play hardball and go no no no
no no no to all these requests or take
it one step further
and say do we as is that demand
there so look there's two sides of the
story on on that one
you can't thinking there
thanks here's the other side
other than a number of years there have
been people who've decided that you know
shifting to odotara would seem very
desirable to them they get out there
having lived in the city and they missed
all those services that they had and
they certainly think why can't we have
footpaths why can't we have Street
lighting why can't we have a rubbish
collected why can't we have uh
connection to sewerage and water
and so there is always that increasing
pressure that comes from people who've
made a decision and
maybe they're not necessarily thought
everything through but from the why
can't you add
just a little more
in in Resource Management terms that's
it's a really common request
um but it is actually limited by the
capacity of the infrastructure I mean
ultimately if you keep stretching
something it's it's gonna break
um and if you keep adding more houses to
the pipeline
um everybody else is going to lose water
pressure and you have a whole lot of
people I mean
I get that somebody wants to add and
there might be a way that you can add an
additional property
into a subdivision but it might be a
part of the requirements that it is not
connected to services this is not new
this is something that
is just business that we have to deal
with and assess each one on on a
case-by-case based on on the capacity
here in did you have something if that's
okay I just want to make sure that we've
got all of the information to think
about whilst we're making decisions
probably two points that I'd make is
just around
um the the pipe Network side of it
um is that Council through the long-term
plan workshops has put an action on the
infrastructure team to look at areas
where infrastructure could enable
greater levels of housing to be
um potentially achieved this is
obviously one of those things where the
infrastructure strategy and the approach
that we have taken has been around not
enabling that we haven't been looking at
a growth strategy for invercargill we've
been looking at where currently this
size actually potentially we're going to
lose population so no we're not looking
to try to achieve greater housing I
guess what I'd say is if we continue
with that approach that may be one of
those outcomes that we're not maximizing
that ability for for new housing that
Council may be seeking so that's one of
the ways we could achieve that the other
one is just around things like street
lights
um and and footpaths
um and I'm sure you know odatara is a
nice easy example but there's definitely
other areas of the network as well
um that I absolutely understand people
have moved to areas and they
um just need to accept the services that
are there which I don't have a problem
with at all my only concern is when we
have in we've allowed intensification of
an area to the point where you've got
large groups of school children walking
through the dark on the edge of the road
that safety piece of council was aware
there was a problem there was a call for
this potentially and has Council
discharged its responsibility to make
sure perhaps intersections are lit
appropriately there is somewhere for
children to be getting safely to and
from school those sorts of things so I
guess this is something that I have
asked the team to have a look at because
I'm aware that in my previous life at
other councils we had done a lot more
proactively in those areas where for one
one reason or another intensification
had happened to then look at whether or
not there was appropriate safe
infrastructure in place to support that
yeah
for us I think you also
what does 25 24 3 look like
30 years time what does odatara look
like because whatever we do now
because in 1993 whatever whatever we've
currently got is what we started with so
we have an opportunity and I guess
that's the input into the infrastructure
strategy is
what do we actually want it to look like
it's a lot easier for us if it stays the
same you may want it to look different
one one point I think it came up on a
couple of slides ago was around your
team can you go back a couple Sports
asset management skills in-house so
that's you're talking to restart
capability that
being a smart client and actually having
the right skill sets across our
organization to be able to make sure
we've got good decisions in a long-term
sense yeah and I mean that's the main
thing that we
in a sense the only thing we can
truly influence
is making sure we've got the very best
people who are thinking through all
these challenges and understand
the cost of a reverse depreciation or if
it's you know the alternative solution
you know that's the only way we're going
to get the best outcome in my view so
what are we doing around
a capability any infrastructure team to
make sure we've got good succession we
don't lose the intellectual property we
have around our assets if someone leaves
or those sorts of things
um look it's a real it's a real
challenge for us we it's not so much
about actually trying to plan for people
who are leaving we don't have the people
in the first place
um and some of the the some of the
challenges through this ltp process have
come to the fore in that and that we've
sort of sat down and run some workshops
around what are some of the different
challenges and constraints that we see
on on the network and whether or not we
can appropriately
um make the best decisions based on some
of those anecdotal challenges that we
have and we came up with a list far
longer of asset management type data
tasks that we needed to do before we
could actually make informed decisions
around what we needed to do from an
investment perspective
it's a national issue and we are slowly
building the team but it's not happening
as fast as we'd like and we are doing
some work sort of with those National
working groups around how we can try to
build strength in that space yeah
because I mean I've just recently spent
some time with Canterbury University and
the the undergraduates there are such
impressive people and you know there's a
great opportunity I think for us in with
esot to potentially look at
Partnerships during holidays those sorts
of things to introduce you know young
people to our organization but equally
get the opportunity to have them come in
steps so I think we've got to be really
Innovative around that
thank you sir you chair um what I would
add to that is that we've it's perfectly
put up there with the very last two
words which is smart client we have to
be smart in both fronts about
recruitment in relation to what Aaron
just said that and and yourself in
relation to the resourcing that's out
there and making sure we're working with
politics and universities all the
education side to make sure we've got
the people coming through but the
challenge is wider than that because of
some of the work that we need is highly
technical from that perspective and
we'll need to be smart about how we
acquire that that's not resources we'll
keep on site at all times we will buy
that in from that perspective so we know
when you do that that you don't retain
that expert but hopefully with the data
that we will improve on we will be able
to retain the data from that perspective
so the data becomes Mission critical
from our perspective
Tom
yeah
um well I thought you were heading
towards it Michael you never quite got
there but
maybe I'll take it you know and in this
day and age we were prepared to have
people sitting at home working on a
computer
um where the connectivity is such that
um you could really be anywhere in the
world
then although I hate myself for saying
this because we only want employment
here but it does seem to me that you
know technical expertise can be housed
anywhere
in fact anywhere in the world
and and it may be that some of these
highest technical roles if we cannot
recruit for them
it might be that the the recruit to
certain Christchurch or Beijing to do
the work
um and I don't personally think that's
necessarily a terrible outcome no no my
Point's more around the capability of
the people we have working for us is
going to be a critical success factor to
how we meet the challenge and more of
you
throw yourself chair might just respond
to Tom because he was his would have
been right except for I don't think
we've got the connectivity in our data
and that's that's why I didn't go there
um you're right I would have gone there
uh we need to do some improvement in
relation to our data connectivity so we
can actually share it a little bit
easier
um that is a focus of mine and it's a
focus on my team going forward but
that's going to take us a little bit to
get there and yes that would be a
long-term goal in relation to that and I
don't mean years and years and years I'm
hoping in the next couple of years
um look if we're looking at growth
forecasts I would have to say that
invercargill would have a reasonably
optimistic one with the
lifestyle that people are facing around
the busy uh the bigger cities transport
taking an hour to get to work and that
that would be a quite that'd be a quick
trip
um I can actually see just from what I'm
hearing for
colleagues talking around New Zealand
they are just
quite happy to get out of the big cities
and
hate to say this but climate change
change seems to be benefiting
invercargill it's it's not a positive
thing to say but
in reality we're all facing it we're
having the best Summers we're um I think
the portrait of invercargill being the
cold damn place it used to be is is
certainly not there and so if I was if I
was giving an opportunity to put a punt
on uh on uh population growth and then
I'd be right behind it to say that we
must be planning seriously for and so
that the housing the the allocation of
land the infrastructure that Russell was
talking about
we have to we can't sit with a ecstatic
sort of BAU
um I think this is the time to do it
regardless of whatever fate uh three
Waters has yeah fair enough are we
um you know and just to reinforce that
we would we had a presentation by
Anthony UC general manager of the
Richardson group recently at Merrell
forum and they're they're struggling to
recruit as well we've got about 300
vacancies and we asked him why he said
the two big issues that prevent people
coming here is quality of Housing and
and the rental market is non-existent
uh and and the other issue was the
access to GPS and dentists and people
were actually turning away because of
that there and I'm not surprised at the
latter because I wouldn't have thought
that would have been most people's
thinking when they were eyeing up a new
job can I get a GP at the other end but
clearly that's the issue and certainly
the housing one was bigger and we know
about the housing we've had over two
decades so it's not just the quantity
it's the quality as well yeah these new
Industries they're going to recruit
people in mid-range and above and they
don't want to be sitting in some of the
houses that we've currently got
available
so we've got a challenge yeah
but the challenge could be uh smaller
units or going upwards as opposed to
going outwards yeah
right we might bring that piece of your
finished for us thank you very much for
taking us through that and appreciate
your consistent work in this area here
in villages to us so thank you
um we'll take lunch and then we're back
at 1 30. yeah yeah okay so 1 30. back in
here thank you
please all good to go
okay so welcome back to those online
stream second part of the session is
with regard to the financial strategy so
um Patricia's going to take us through
there and then
um we'll take questions at the end just
so we get through it quite quickly
um councilor sofa is leaving us shortly
so just feel free to go when you're able
to basically
bye
um good afternoon councilors so there's
a similar um
sort of cadence to what Russell went
through this morning so again we've
listed out what our key decisions
are in relation to the financial
strategy so I've already gone through
what we're required by law to put in a
financial strategy but there's some
pretty key assumptions that will
underpin it
so the probably the biggest one or the
two biggest ones of course uh um and
we'll go through these in in detail
further through so we've got our
inflation and our interest rates
uh as Russell alluded to uh this morning
we've got to look at that how we fund
our infrastructure approach
um also in relation to we've always put
in a capital program delivery assumption
into a strategy as well
and then we look at affordability and
our balance budgets and making provision
for a natural disaster
we'll get through to that that's already
been raised this morning as well so
go to the first one
inflation
so given that we have
ltp is a 10-year plan
so we're going to have to make some
assumptions around inflation for the
next 10 years but also we need to put it
into the infrastructure and financial
strategies for 20 years beyond that so
there is some long run assumptions being
used here
um
and we'll do operating costs we will
also look at wage costs secretly
especially for the first three years
and then North and as well as their
Capital inflation so these are expected
in October
um
I've made the comment there that they'll
be higher than the last ltp was
projecting they'll probably be about
double
um
we will um so they will come with
assumptions with and without water as
well
so what would our inflation look like
and the local government cost index if
local government has water if local
government doesn't have water
so that will allow us to give us some
better assumptions and
um bill undertakes this exercise for the
sector
um and they developed the local
government cost index so they have said
that they will give the two options this
year
in relation to interest rates we've got
to do both what we think our borrowing
will be
and also what cash Holdings
and I'll remind councilors that we said
we would maintain as part of our care
and management and debt management
strategy and a liquidity strategy that
we would Main Rim hold 20 million
and cash for liquidity purposes
and that also Shores up our balance
sheet for both emergency
and um helps us with um credit rating as
well
and then the third assumption is on our
Capital delivery
now the only reason we have this
assumption is that
everyone tends to put too much into the
capital program
and it's a realization that if I was to
go borrow based on what the capital
program said
that I might actually be over I would
probably over borrow messages
so where we have set it
currently is that it sit at 85 of the
renewal program
so your strategic projects are expected
to be 100 delivered well the year which
the borrowing might sit in might move a
little bit if something's is going to be
110 million it's not these hundreds 10
million it'll be 10 million
um
the renewals were saying well we might
whatever we've got in for that renewal
program
things could happen
and things may not get delivered so what
we're actually saying there is only 85
percent
will get delivered
however if we said actually let's
as a strategy and as a council that we
would only put forward capital programs
that are able to be delivered
we could adjust that assumption
it would be in a really great space as a
council for us to get to where we knew
we could deliver
a hundred percent of our renewals
program
it's quite normal to risk adjust Capital
programs because the reality is in any
organization and if it all get done
um and in terms of projects I presumably
85 percent is based on a historical
average delivery the and in terms of
projects if it tube is based on
historical average request what average
would we have percentage with MSA in the
last 10 years uh I bet it's not 100 no
it's not 100 that's 150 percent
maybe between 50 and 17. I'm looking at
Russell because he's probably got a
better thing my my history here is much
shorter than Russell's it's as a sector
local government's normally sitting in
that 50 to 80.
Lego council is delivering 80. I would
say some of them are going to 90 but
we've taken look rather than looking at
historically looking at how we are
currently organized to deliver our
capital
so we have a pmo to deliver a strategic
asset both strategic projects so that is
their core function
that's what they've been charged with so
that's I'm quite happy with that it's
whether we can get from 85 to 90 or 95
with the other ones but that's until we
start seeing that's one of those last
assumptions
that we've got to play with
the other really key issue is funding
infrastructure
taking a very traditional approach here
that we fund by rates or we
all we borrow
there are other ways that are coming in
and emerging in the sector
but I think from a long-term strategy we
are best
to say well this there may be other ways
but let's focus on what we've got here
and now and maybe we can change to
something else as it comes through it's
hard to know what the other funding
mechanisms will be
until they arrive
so
it this is all prefaced around who is
the best person who is best place to pay
you users now
all the users over time
um So currently we're funding the
renewal of existing assets
by rates using depreciation as the proxy
for its consumption over the life
that does get adjusted by revaluation so
we know that
what was probably go back to Russell
using 1993.
um 30 years ago to replace a section of
footpath versus
that same section of footpath today will
be very different
and so therefore as we go through an
inflationary period the cost to replace
those assets goes up
um
with new and improved assets
our strategy has been to debt fund those
and then rate for the interest cost and
the debt repayment over 25 to 30 years
apologies for the spelling mistake
um
the other option that we've got is to
rates fund fire renewals so we come up
with a
Russell and between the infrastructure
strategy and the financial strategy we
come up with a renewals number per annum
and we fit the renewals program into
that number
and we write for
15 million of renewals for the council
or 10 million and we got 10 million
every year of asset renewals and that's
what we write for
very blunt
um but it is another way of doing it
however there is the risk that you get
20 years into that such a strategy and
you haven't you have a significant
inflationary period
you may not have enough you're not going
to deliver
10 meters of footpath for this you might
not have enough money for your 10 meters
of football
and the new and improved I've still
could still be other option is still to
fund it but you might go closer to the
30 years or we go to even longer
that say actually we do our Capital
repayment over 40 years
so that's sort of the quandary that
we're at and when we bring the financial
strategy back I may actually do it with
both options
of renewals if that's what you are
that if you want to see what the
difference will be
we have to do it as a long term what the
difference would be between those two
okay with the if we write the funded for
renewals how how good's your information
to be able to accurately assess what
area and renewals needs to be because we
you know you don't want to be if you go
down that track you don't want to be
under investing do you
know gee I think that's one of your
risks is that your your data information
is Reliant
and
I think it's you try to do both of those
you're trying to understand what your
consumption is because you your base
life is what you you need to be looking
at I think one of the problems we face
is that we're actually some of a lot of
our assets are two-thirds of the way
through their life already so part of
the challenge that we face is that
um
we don't want to replace things by age
we want to replace them by need and I
guess that's the challenge of actually
being able to find and it's much easier
in footpaths because you can see the
things the pipes a bit more difficult
and we've got some of those big lumps
coming
um people talk about a bell wave of
things happening um
the difficult the thing was that your
general engineering people will try to
smooth it out that's that's the general
nature of what everybody tries to do but
somewhere in time it does start to catch
you up on you know
AJ Wellington has a problem with the
water pipes
I think we've avoided some of those
things because we've been ahead of the
game but
we had some really strong Peaks of
construction in the 50s and 70s in our
city
when they come to the end of their life
they will come to the end of the life
about the same decades and and that will
actually challenge whether you can
afford to fund the amount of renewals of
those periods at that time and that's
your downside other than that you've got
a full sometimes you've got to say
that's our strategy but we actually have
to go up 10 in the preceding five years
or something along those lines but it is
actually
um
and we have to do better than 85 percent
yeah
rang in then Tom yeah like it was just a
question article around
is the uh is the quality or the
technology of our infrastructure
improving just by by suppliers you know
like take for example the massive
stormwater pipes out at the end of the D
Street there are they now are they a
better pipe than we would have had 10 20
years ago oh absolutely some of the
materials we're using now are generally
of a much higher like for instance that
um the standard of a concrete reinforced
pipe compared to an earthenware or a
1950s concrete Pipers just
magnitudes are different but that's
allowed for in the future so this has
all been allowed for by the
manufacturers so he is it the
manufacturers that give you the life or
how do you they give us a suggestion but
then we typically are extending that
because it's a bit like you turn up and
you get a new roof on your house and you
ask the Roof Supply how long will the
roofing material and they'll say
warranted for seven you might get 15 and
everybody replaces at 30. so yeah um how
long is it and that's you know we've got
materials there that we continue to
sample and look at and look at what the
failure mechanisms are and what's
causing that
um on a year by year basis and can
continue to update that information
about what it is that when can we see
the trend happening
um
and if we can push the life out we will
push the life out but that's the
challenge if you've got a renewal's
budget and we've got to spend it
otherwise we won't get to 85 from our
accounting friends no that's that's good
I mean my main question was about the
Improvement in technology which
increases this this Gap yeah and it's
another one whereas the data through
um gets better we can get better at
doing nice as well yeah understanding
the contingency Tom
I think I was probably just going to
reinforce
put Russell replied in response to
rangi's question and that is that you
know critically this is very very good
asset management programs and you know
understand and predictive models
um the the reality is that why spend an
extra two million dollars a year
and Replacements when you could run an
asset management program say for half a
million dollars a year that would avoid
that
um and therefore you know I think we've
got to be prepared to invest in that
kind of because that is how you actually
push out the yeah you know don't replace
it 10 years if you judge that you can
replace it 13 or 14 years that's got a
lot of value but you're taking some risk
but if you've got very good asset
management programs you can mitigate
that risk just by you know good analysis
so I I you know I I think we've got to
be prepared to you know consider
programs coming forward for you know
spending on
um you know Asset Management predicted
models which uh which will allow us to
do these things sometimes a failure
isn't a bad thing because you know
you've actually got pretty close to the
line so long as it's not critical and I
guess that's the criticality of those
pipes that you need to make sure you've
got your house in order that you don't
have that risk so you take risk where
it's appropriate yeah
and that's I guess what historically
we've looked at some of the things like
footpaths and agreed that we might not
necessarily fund those fully at the
depreciation rate because we can do some
minor repairs we can look at them we can
you know you can see some of that stuff
but what I
risk water supply or some of your Rising
Mains that
that's that's where you should that's
where the investment logic applies so so
with their Asset Management Programs
what on a scale of one to ten
how good are they
and your opinion asking the Strategic
Asset Management so that's British it's
all again
sitting in the wolf into the um
I think we continue to learn we we are
part of that is we have an asset
maturity and I guess that's part of what
the rest of the asset triangle looks
looks to have is so where do we want to
where do we want to be and how do we
want to continue to improve so some of
our
um our stormwater and falsura and our
water plans and the roading plan are
probably more mature than some of our
other plans
um our property and air Parks
um I guess just a little bit behind the
data cycle because you know to be fair
and what is paid for the data for from
writing for a long time so you know
we've got lots of data we've done lots
of the deterioration modeling a lot of
that's coming into the three Waters and
and obviously that's where that's being
driven from but we still get we're still
continuing to race behind to catch up on
those other programs as a whole of
council because I guess the
infrastructural strategy deals just with
the parts we tweet and Roads we talked
about whereas uh
Patricia's talks about this is funding
the whole of the rest of the council
asset base as well so um short answer is
we're probably in an intermediate stage
not at a high level yet so but that's
our Target and and that's why we want to
continue to invest in our staff and our
programs so so when we get our paperback
that will address
how we might beef up our asset
management capability and you know
through the use of programs and those
sorts of things like that's going to be
that will be included Within
women to ltp budgets yeah
and that certainly is the opportunity I
know that we've just recently been
working through some of those and
um
be fair to say the infrastructure teams
look reasonably liberally about the the
opportunities that it faces and we'll
wait with baited breath about
what the decision is on some of those
projects and some of it is modeling
just two or three things um Patricia you
mentioned 20 million
um
hold for liquidity and you're talking
about money that's currently sitting in
in our banks yeah so Karen we
um that is part of their cash reserves
that we would keep 20 million dollars as
a liquidity buffer So currently about
40.
it would take some change yeah because
we've got some short-term asset
short-term debt
um the other issue was the issue which
Russell was just talking about about our
appetite for failure as opposed to
maintenance
going Asset Management going forward
um a couple of things to consider I
guess one is that um
new technology will change the landscape
for us so it's not just a matter of
saying let's have a 10 or a 30 year plan
good example is in Queenstown when I was
here they were boasting about the fact
that they've got a a new pipe ceiling
piece of apparatus out of watercare in
Auckland and hadn't given it back
so what it basically does when you had a
damaged pipe it sort of drills it out
and as it goes it puts a silicon seal
around the pipe so you can actually
extend the life if you've got a bit of a
not just a pipe that's gone past its its
final date but it's sort of it's damaged
we would normally wrap it up and replace
it so that sort of technology is on the
horizon I guess and the other one would
be the um the nature of the replacement
and I think somebody already asked for
us all about the issue you know pipes
which might only be 75 years life now
might be 100 years 10 years from now the
different materials being used yeah so
yeah that's good evil
just thinking about what you said about
the 1950s growth and in the 1970s one
proportionally which is the bigger risk
is at the 1970s because it's so
widespread because you've got the whole
of Center Street Regent Street and then
right across to
um kingswell my recollection of the data
is that they are similar but certainly
the Technologies in the 50s weren't as
Superior as the Technologies or the
approaches used in the 70s
and yet again we've actually probably
done less new infrastructure since then
but what we're putting in is better
again so
um that does really high peaks in terms
of
how much we physically did in those
spaces I mean that's when you see the
numbers it's just quite it's it's really
big it's peaky and just an amazing
amount of development that must have
gone on but when it comes to an end it
is also something that you've got to fix
um
so just as we and what we've just been
discussing is where the depreciation
best reflects their consumption of an
asset
um and the other one is that linkage
with the infrastructure strategy so this
is where
these two strategies have to be joined
at the hip
um for them to be
for us to get a good outcome
um the other really key issue is their
key metrics we put in the financial
strategy and I look at this
is the four key limits that we've got so
we have
a balanced budget which is a goal that
we have to have a plan to achieve
we have a limit on rates increases which
is set in the financial strategy a limit
on borrowing so that's what we've called
our debt ceiling for the last three
years and our rates affordability which
is a goal of council it's how we use
those four things
to get the right outcome hence why they
become a pyramid
um
yeah can I just add to that a little bit
um what's missing on that triangle for
me is two other factors one is that some
new industry coming in May contribute
so while we have some growth
um it might be that we get some joint
ventures going with some of the major
industries who want to be here and
secure there
their water in particular and the other
issue is post um
post uh the election if National and
they may very well have a contestable
tax funded
pool of money that we can um use and
we'll probably get less of it than
anywhere else but um that allows us to
soften our rate impact going forward
it helped in terms of new in-person
oh I'm the city Russell how early do
they engage Us in terms of the
infrastructure needs is it too early too
late or about right
generally it's reason me it's reasonable
but it's tends to be on the later side
often they talk on a I guess a very high
level until they can actually establish
that they consort can can secure their
funding and yeah and often that funding
for their projects are a relatively
towards the eight in deadline because I
guess that's the The Challenge and often
they will bring to us um
generalizations about what they're
looking for it's not often deadly
specific and and now down then we have
to do the rest of the work and behind it
so um
a lot depends on each what each one is
and you know how often we we get them
and how much resource we have to
actually
put up that process Tom have you got any
insights there around because well uh so
I guess
um I mean if you look at electrical
infrastructure where you get a new
business coming and they want it set up
and it's going to require a new
Transformer yeah substations and so
forth
um they have two choices
they can either fund it themselves
um and then they don't pay the same you
know ongoing charge or else they can
have the
um lines business it usually is
um fund it
uh but then they pay it back over a
period of you know 25 or 30 years
effectively it's a loan that's given by
the
um by the infrastructure company to but
are still going to be paid back and and
usually the decision if it's if they're
smart about it depends on who's got
those cost of borrowing yeah you know
that's if they talk well enough to each
other it depends on that but but if you
look at like um
nearly everything was funded by
electricity and Ricardo Lane recovery
line charges if you look at the perk
company quite a substantial amount of
their work it is actually funded by
Capital
um contribution by the the business
right
um because it's usually we in Wales some
place and you're going to paint a whole
lot infrastructure so they pay for it
they need up paying charges right and I
don't know whether we get that same
option we've had a number of um we've
got a few pipelines where they are
single industry use predominantly or
perhaps there's a little bit of City
stuff goes into them but they get funded
by the industry and invest it it's no
different than a subdivision and an
effect when someone builds a new
subdivision they pay for the whole
infrastructure everything and then
they're vested in terms of council and
then we take over that and then we
maintain it ongoing but I guess in most
of those situations we get that ongoing
nature because we also can claim rates
across those people so it's if you had
huge subdivisional and extra work then
you would actually start to see
increased maintenance costs and other
factors but one of the things we've been
really fortunate is we've actually had
capacity when you think about the my
earlier comments that there's actually
been capacity or just about all of our
networks to be able to either do the one
and two lots or the bigger stuff we
haven't had the demands that some of the
bigger cities have had where you've got
to replace a pipe because we haven't got
stuff that's big enough we're we're
getting to there but we have just about
used our spear capacity generally
places but if if they said where would
you put it and that's what Aaron was
alluding to us where can we if he said
where would we put infrastructure we
would say over there because the pipes
aren't busy so put up there but that
doesn't often always suit people yeah
look I'm just
um
Russell looking at the news article that
we're called a steward announced their
industrial park and it it says here
austral Asia's biggest heavy industrial
Business Pack and this is still
obviously not in concrete yet but if it
goes ahead
can can we handle it with what we've got
or do we is is this a game changer for
us
it's cheap I'm not 103 hectares I'm not
fully aware of what they what their
demands are a lot will depending what
they put in there
yeah if it's heavy water for the water
stuff for water and waste that's the tip
typically it's easy to find water than
because you have big sheds you can
capture water it's actually how you
manage the disposal of your waste which
seems to be the greatest challenge that
everybody both land subdivision and
Industrial and that's where
um we will actually have that ongoing
challenge ourselves as we have our
um so so we haven't been approached yet
um I haven't been but it doesn't mean to
say that there's elsewhere in the
council we're in what okay I mean look
it's a great announcement
and it looks very real
it's just yeah yeah and that's probably
a bit of the challenge I'm alluding to
is you know we need to be engaged pretty
early because of our plans yeah why that
the impact on our planning and provision
and we don't want to not provide so they
don't come either so it's equally that
we don't have to be the only people that
actually treat waste and dispose of it
they may well wish at a size of an
industrial subdivision they may well
choose to come up with a methodology
where they could equally do that
themselves yeah that's true yeah if you
take I'm sorry sorry and then Tom yeah
um
the initial question was how how early
are people engaging and what's their
thinking around the discussions I've had
recently with hydrogen in data banks and
tolex everything with salmon they all
want security of water yeah you're not
worried about footpaths or roads or
electricity which surprised me that the
water angle and the key word there was
the security not just the water yeah
they don't want to invest in some cases
billions of dollars only to find out
they run short of water which is
critical for their operation but look it
seems to me that these people are open
to some investment in the infrastructure
themselves which is Russell Salud
because certainly when I put it to
um Woodside about the housing they said
oh they were quite chest puffed out and
you know we're going to have 2 000
workers here building the plant I said
we're going to house them we don't have
housing for 2 000 workers
um and then they they sort of said well
hey what could we do with that that's
all so they came up with a workers camp
or two
maybe 300 houses transportable of course
I then said to them well that's great
um so what are you gonna do and when you
finish with it because you only got 200
workers in the plan so I think a tenth
of it
oh don't know I said well could you gift
them to the city as part of your Social
license and they were up for that so
they showed me that I guess that they're
they're wanting to be more than just a
drop in and you provide it and we'll
we'll bring the big plant along they're
quite happy I think in this day I used
to get the security and to invest a
little bit in the infrastructure as
opposed to just the industry they're in
so I think there's an option there for
us so we get in early
is alluding to as well
and maybe one of the things we look
operationally is have someone on staff
that is the key contact so that we
capture those connections and networks
and get played through to Russell's
Department pretty quickly around here
what they're thinking and how we might
manage it yeah as opposed to waiting for
businesses to kind of put a consent in
yeah to get somebody on the front foot
as soon as we hear something's going on
make the contact First yeah foreign
Capital Investments like you know the
hydrogen plant that might be you know
three or four billion dollars or
something like that by the time you you
know modify the port and unloading and
all that sort of thing it'll be billions
of dollars and I would expect you know
based on you know other projects that
I've been involved in they would assume
that they'd provide their own
infrastructure I would expect yeah I I
would expect me if it didn't boars
um or you know they they will they will
assume that in this Capital estimates
yeah and if if they can persuade us to
seek some of that off their hands then
they'll be delighted at that but I would
I would expect if there's somebody
sitting somewhere at the moment
and would say dinner Capital estimate
they will include the cost of those
things and I'll be absolutely certainly
they will but I think I think what they
were saying was that Tom was that they
were saying if we're doing some drilling
at the moment and when we were doing the
drilling before it was on an emergency
water backup
and if we now wanted the front end of
part of their supply they'd be prepared
to be involved with that well well it
could be in a large idea of you know the
the water that comes out of the um
Wastewater you know we could pump that
down to them for cooling and it doesn't
have to be you know consumable level
though but it could be a great way we
can do a partnership with them and so we
actually solve a problem together yeah
and I think that's the sort of thing I
think we should really be trying to
bring forward yeah it's called potable
water yeah yeah yeah and the data banks
want exactly the same thing yeah so
instead of them just doing their thing
over here you know maybe we can solve a
problem
for each other by working more
collaboratively together so that'd be
great to see anyway even
um
the uh on what we can
well
provide for those huge big activities as
opposed to our business as usual
um and I think it comes back to the
conversations that we've had about
subdivisions and and places where we
don't currently have reticulated service
and all those sorts of things you want
to have your subdivision we're not going
to provide the service that's you know
that's the bottom line it's outside of
our reticulation area we don't encourage
you to subdivide the air if you want to
do that you have to provide your own
um water sources disposable sources all
those sorts of things and it all has to
fit within the
uh within the legislation because I
think otherwise we get pushed into
chasing these developments and over
capitalizing the city or over committing
the city oh yeah
um you know if we're sending the signal
we're open for this but these are the
things we will not do or these are the
things we cannot do
um and then people are with a no doubt
um
we've been talking to
data grid and one of the things we said
to them was
um you're in an area
theoretically where the aquifers under a
little bit of pressure what are you
going to do in terms of your development
to not put further pressure on and
they'd already thought about that so
Tom's exactly right
um they're making big Capital
Investments and they do the what-ifs
what if I can't get
um water and then at the other end of it
how do I dispose of it once it's been
through our system seven times or
whatever I think they said the maximum
number of um Cycles is you know so I
mean
we don't have to take it all on
ourselves and we shouldn't take it all
on ourselves and the signal which we
should be sending to people is we really
are interested but you have to build in
your own independence because this is
not within the capacity of the city rate
payers to do it for you
sorry yeah Mr and only because this
Council hasn't come across it before so
you might not even be aware of it but
the other bit the council lever does
have is development contributions yeah
and it's something that this Council has
always shied away from because it's
always felt that that was an incentive
to get development but you might find
that if you uh if that's switching and
you're getting a big Bell wave of
development you might find that you
might want to reconsider that position
because it does relieve that pressure
that you otherwise so what was it called
again I missed the stuff uh development
contributions so we do have both
development and financial contributions
slightly different
um but I thought we couldn't do one of
those you can do development
contributions because you tend to do
them because they're putting pressure on
whether it's community that and you have
to give them back
um there is some other ways that we if
it's industrial that you see as the
those that the pressure that's going on
the system
that there may be way that we could come
up with something
you need to make the call as to whether
or not they need to be replaced you
can't put them in place once you've
received the application so now is the
time so I'll add that and they come back
as well
development contributions I guess for
bigger projects can be by agreement I
would
see it's because it's a it's a
contribution that's a mutual agreement
um often development contributions are
where you've got a subdivision for
instance for a gravel road and people
will pay a little bit early but what you
do tend to find is that there's a break
point where the three people have paid
the development then you've got to do
the rest and wait for your money to come
back and often that seem to be it's a
long and painful process to be fair and
I guess Council some while ago
considered that and considered it wasn't
necessary at the time because we were
trying to encourage people to do growth
It's actually an inhibitor in some
places some councils have quite
um I guess expensive uh costs to join
networks and typically you know if you
join a you might do an Asura or a water
Network and a for a just a simple
subdivision it could be several thousand
dollars in some of the places in
Auckland I know it's tens of thousands
of dollars per utility to subdivide your
presidential property you're probably
thinking of a comment on that
um I mean it's different when you get
co4 people put in a garage a little
subdivision but if we are talking about
uh you know hydrogen plant I would say
to something like that
um they would expect to provide these
yes they would expect it and and they
they will be gone almost certainly
they'll end up using Chinese money I
suspect they'll be born in at one or two
percent
they don't want us to do something and
end up paying it back to us if we had
bought on at five or six percent so you
know that that tends to be how these
projects think yeah yeah
okay so the key
the kid nipped it and I'm proposing that
in the financial strategy we continue to
use that net debt construct which if you
think about it it's a revolving credit
facility for each activity they say they
might go up they might go down they pay
interest and the council is the bank
so that's the way to think about when we
talk about net debt some will make small
surpluses but then the next year they
may need to use that Surplus because of
the timing of projects things like that
the one change and I know well
um the mayor said that we didn't think
there needs to be too much that changes
in the financial strategy the one I'd
like to consider is rather than
concentrating on a debt ceiling limit
how much we could borrow we focus on how
much we can afford to service and we set
that level based on if the interest
rates at four percent or five percent
this is how much is going to cost us
this is the rates that come out so it's
a sort of like solve the equation
backwards a little bit so what's their
maximum Finance cost and how much
borrowing does that actually allow
frequent yeah
what's that option
does that potentially restrict us with a
say infrastructure program where we've
met a period of work to be done over a
period of time
but if increasing interest rates on what
we're already serving
go high enough could that impact the
amount of work that we're able to do in
the next year
and how it would audit respond to that
okay it could but then when we developed
this construct we'd probably stress test
it to see whether it does work it may be
that we have this discussion now or go
away we model it and come back and go
actually it might not work
and we need to go back the other way
um we always know that we sh will be
able to borrow her Headroom will be
significantly more on the other way
but the concern with that is that the
cost to service that debt if we got
towards that debt ceiling would put a
rate a burden on there right purse
because we don't borrow to pay interest
yeah you'll be able to fluctuate your
work with that the rising lowering
interest rates anyway wouldn't you yeah
so what you know you do less now do more
later you know unless you've got a
criticality oh no historically it
changes
boy yearly really doesn't it yeah
it's like this forever yeah yeah you get
a sensitivity to how much rates where
they're at and how where they're going
and then you know at eight percent we
can't do any other level program yeah
but you do it all next year yeah yeah
yeah are we just two things
when we talk before about the net uh
development contribution
um there is also the opportunity yeah
especially in the hydrogen space
for them to um reduce our costs so we
talked before about what happens if we
have to do uh discharge the land and how
far would the piping be to get the
parcel land that could take the
discharge that we have every every year
it'll be huge so if I'm taking if we
could take the same waste down to
wherever the hydrogen plant is and they
get rid of all of it we get nothing back
at the end of that any discharge back at
the end of it that's a huge cost yeah
that's right you hear a lot of these
projects now not talking about that sort
of stuff they talk about social
licensing
and so interesting thing about social
licensing well if we were putting some
infrastructure say a few million dollars
worth of infrastructure to from A to B
um and that same company then put two or
three million dollars or whatever into a
new museum is that social licensing that
has a good spin for us and a good spin
for them as well yeah
um but the other issue was the issue of
these reserves that we keep having
and we keep talking about I think you
suddenly said to Russell before how much
of the Catholics do we do every year
well I can't comment on the
three Waters camping school I don't know
but certainly in the last
two terms anyway three terms that I've
been watching Council we've not
delivered what we said we can deliver so
it seems to me just about every year but
not every year we run at a surplus and
for those who've been around Darren and
others will remember that about four or
five years ago we had this debate about
Hang on we're putting two million
dollars into reserves but we just put
the rates up two million dollars it just
didn't make any sense and one of the
Cycles I think we caught up on is that
we predict our rate increases and build
for them even before the end of the
financial year so we get ahead of that
but our financial results don't come out
to about September October
um I always told me you realize we've
got a surplus and I suspect that I know
those reserves that we've had recent
times have been up around the 50 million
dollar Mark and that's just not that's
just not Revenue that we've that we've
mystically found it's it's where we've
over quoted what we're going to use and
we've actually under spent and and for
ratepayers that doesn't settle that well
sometimes I know it's good to have it
for the net debt purposes but there's
got to be a balance somewhere along the
line that we're not predicting say next
year five percent a week 2.2 2.3 million
dollars worth of rate increases it
wouldn't be good if at the end of the
year we were two million under spent
um and just put it aside if we take it
and put it into I don't know Saving
Grace or something that's another killer
fish altogether but there is a constant
tension at the end of each year yeah
like this rise in interest costs you
know affecting the infrastructure and
everything you completely understand it
but I'm just reading an article here
about self-adjusted Council proposing
massive massive rates increases
and that's and their excuse is rise in
interest costs on infrastructure now and
obviously
I thought you would have some sort of
smoothing effect that would cover
um your borrowings and everything so you
weren't at risk or you could foresee or
whatever but obviously the rates
increases when you correlate them back
then the increases in interest costs to
these guys must be quite phenomenal
they must yeah they're really exposed
well they're not they borrowed 100
million dollars to invest
I think part of it is they've also
looked to borrow so they can reinvest
yeah that's right yeah but anyway so
they've exposed themselves but the
direct impact is on is that what you're
suggesting we do no no no that's what
we're saying that that if you're looking
at interest cost fluctuations which we
know they're probably still increasing
is that they've obviously exposed
themselves
to to I mean the right decrease is not
like a one percent rate increase it's
phenomenal yeah I've got an issue with
um a lot of um the infrastructure hasn't
been kept up for years aren't they way
behind the eight ball no no it's purely
referring to interest cost increases so
if the interest hadn't gone up it would
be clean sandwich so this is just
exposes what Patricia's raised here yeah
we just need to be really good at full
code yeah right sensitizing
a deep position
Stephanie at Tom no just I think we've
probably covered it before but I mean
the key to the I guess this question
marks against
the second Point
um
as overlooked period do you assume
because a few uh assume the rate that
you look at in newspaper that day then
you wouldn't be born in anything no
that's right um but if you and it's
unpredictable it may be completely
different tomorrow if you make an
assumption over 10 years it's far more
predictable and you know you it may be
assume five percent or something so I
mean my question would be
um if we were going down our track over
what period over what average period
really assuming interest rate
so we look at the interest rate over the
first 10 years 15 and then but we're
number 10 to 50 we we look at it over a
period and go well what's the average
but we also look at what's rolling off
our own book so at the moment I think at
April away or March Eric waited a cost
of capital cost of borrowing was about
2.3 percent because we've got a lot of
fixed debt at low
as we go through the else we know that's
going to roll off into what that new
debt will come on at so air rates will
go up
but then we look at what that long run
and because we tend to borrow long
so we tend to borrow a lot of our big
stuff at long periods knowing that we're
probably
depending on what we're borrowing for
we'll fix that so that's part of our
liquidity management right so if we were
doing that you're seeing that over 15
years it may be you would assume an
interest rate of five percent or someone
Finance course might be a little bit
lower than that read it more than that
so so I mean on that basis I think that
makes up sort of sense
okay this is probably the other one
that's going to be a biggest issue in
the financial strategy and that is
coming a plan to come back to a balanced
budget
and a balanced budget
is literally that our total revenue
is greater than our total expenses
but they do take out some Revenue gets
taken out of the calculation so any
invested assets
and all that which is revenue so creates
an accounting Surplus
but it's not really Revenue
um
so it's also the largest cost impacting
this is depreciation so that's why we
have gone to an unbalanced budget
for as we've said the ltp the annual
plan sorry we'll have an unbalanced
budget because of how we've chose to
fund depreciation
so we need to over the course of the
strategy come back to within the ltp
coming back to a balanced budget
position
so that will be one challenge when we
write the strategy is that this to be
prudent we need to come back to a
balanced budget
um
in isolation the answer is easy as I say
yeah increase your revenue or you
decrease the expenses and practice try
to do that
while trying to achieve everything else
we want to achieve will be much more
difficult
it's a third I mean a third option is
you increase your asset life assumption
and therefore depreciate over a longer
period yes so how free are we do that
we can do that
though we do review that every time we
do a asset revaluation I was going to
say every three years but it's proving
to be less than three years that we have
to reevaluate so that is a valid
option that is a valid option because if
we believe that through Asset Management
good asset management and better
materials and so forth
then the the assets are going to last
longer going to last 25 years instead of
20 years then that reduces by 20
actually your rate depreciation so that
that's a significant impact on the and
the one challenge we would have by doing
that would be to try and get us through
audit sure because we'd have to be able
to prove that that was already yeah that
made it easier than increasing
everybody's rates by 15 one year yeah
but now it circles back to your point
Tom around the you know really good
asset management programs because that
is the information we're inform the
decision to change your depreciation
rate right so it goes back to we need to
have really good information
so Mr chair there's a quite a range of
guidelines that uh issued nationally and
through the international Asset
Management manual which is the Baseline
which we push to the right to the
the far end so we have
not underestimated our asset live so we
continue to have reasonably long asset
lives and and where we've actually got
any justification we wouldn't we we have
tried to extend them out as far as we
think are logical whether there's more
evidence to support it is the the
problem and and often we're only in the
first life cycle of our of our assets if
you think about that our pipes have only
had one life cycle in the road and then
the ground whereas our roads we've got a
lot much much more reliable because they
we've had several life cycles so that's
that Balancing Act of how we actually
come up to a number that's appropriate
yeah Navi yeah I I've seen I've seen
this in previous occasions as well but I
think yeah yeah and we have an unhealthy
focus on a balanced budget
um it's okay to be unbalanced if you
know traditionally that you've actually
end up with a result that was Surplus
most of the way through a five or a ten
year period and it's built up by
reserves because of that so uh I'm not
suggesting we go to unbalanced budgets
every year but there are times when
you've got pressure on and safer homes
that we've got pressure on now with the
cost of living for for our community to
actually run with an unbalanced budget
that might show at the front end that
we're going to run out of money
um towards the end but in practice
history would tell us that we're not
going to run out of money and we've
still got the the backdrop of the
reserve sitting there I'm quite healthy
reserved at that
oh yeah
other key issue that we have to
look at is our reliance
and Reliance on and reliability of
external funding
so this will become during the when we
when the engine when the ltp gets
audited this is a key focus on audit if
we are putting in third party funding
external funding for capital projects
um
is that actually going to be received
wakakatahi because it is the ltp
coincides with that funding round
so that is normally the last of them
that gets finalized into a budgets but
from a
we just need to be mindful
that this while it's a valid Revenue
source
that we can't become overly reliant on
it or that it's got to be actually we've
got to see the color of the money
to go we think we're going to get 10
million dollars in external funding for
this project
how confident do we feel and
using the DPMS words what's the risk
associated with it
and we'd probably likely to be more
conservative to say we might get two but
we'd hope to get 10.
and that's where we need to because it's
be in the last
three years been such a significant part
of their budgets that it will have to
feature within the financial strategy
and going forward especially for the
first half
of the ltp
that will be important
so against you the
um the compensating for that by rates is
not only approach I mean you just cut
your suit to suit your clothes if you
have less external funding you do less
yes
well typically where we've balanced it
off has been with borrow more
and so that's where if it's a large
project that we're getting third party
funding we're probably borrowing on the
other side so it's that balance between
debt and third party funding
so we're not necessarily rating
we because we wouldn't normally rate for
that for interest rating for interest
but it's much better to say we might be
higher in outer years and come in lower
example is
I mean I can't believe that that it's it
still exists on its own funding
mechanism it only receives through Felix
size Road user charges
um but there is no tax
none of our tax money
that our income tax money goes into what
and it's a model I can't see I can't see
how it can continue because the demand
for transport routing all over New
Zealand far outweighs
what it earns now I'd hate to be doing
the box for Waka katahi it must be the
most unbalanced budget known to mankind
because I can't see how it cannot
increase its income and with the Advent
of electric cars there you goes less
fuel and no room no Road user charges
but Demand on the road so
I just don't know when
the government is gonna
wake up and smell the roses and say we
need a different funding model to work
at katahi
uh it just defies logic well they are
reviewing that now with electric cars
aren't they ah look anyway yeah so you
need to be careful you vote for next
time yep
the National Party position on that is
labor don't get rid of excise tax and
Road use attacks and then all vehicles
regardless whether they're EVS or not
will have a classification yes by
kilometers I've asked labor about that
as well
um and then going down that track as
well I think because they realize the
model's broken with cocaine but they
just don't want to be seen to be green
with something with national this day so
the other comment I like was uh
um what you said Patricia about you know
we want 10 million dollars from some
Grant and we considerably think we might
get two or three or four so we we budget
very conservatively but the trouble is
that when we get too conservative as Tom
quite rightly raises we end up then
having to subsidize more more debt
um so that's that's a risk for me
um and certainly if it packs on rates
it's
definitely a worry we shouldn't be quite
so conservative because if you think
about a big project well which is the
next big one of the museum
we've got um lots of options here to
raise funds some are dependent on others
some come later in the cycle as opposed
to early but we should be able to get
that across the line and we shouldn't be
considered to say hey we need to put
some more in
um because that's absolutely the last
equation part of the equation so we'd
have to fund it that way
through you must I think in response to
what um is saying I think you did right
though when we put the museum in in the
last ltp we had to be conservative the
numbers we put in for the museum
and this ltp will be able to be much
more realistic because we have more
information sure if you're putting a
project out in year six or seven and
it's going to have some external funding
you can't be that certain and that's
what I'm meeting would be likely to be
on the low side rather than on the high
side
so some argue to that would be just do a
few projects that you can actually
deliver and not have too much of wish
list out in the front that you're
subsequently building to a rate forecast
yeah
foreign okay
and the last key issue from the funny
and the financial strategy will be the
funding and the provision for a natural
disaster
this is a key audit issue one of the few
that we know about already
um
legislatively we have to fund 40 percent
of rebuild costs
um the government provides the balance
so we have to have that's 40 of
infrastructure
don't self-insured open infrastructure
we do actually ensure our infrastructure
well we do ensure we have some insurance
it is the local 30 Asset Protection
Program it's not foreign for our pipe
networks but we don't we don't insure
our roading networks including Bridges
so that's predominantly because you also
fund co-fund
so um we don't have any insurance on our
roads so the point I was trying to get
to so 40 of the rebuild costs means 40
of the uninsured rebuild costs
presumably yes
um and that's another reason for having
the deadhead room so it tends to become
you've got to have that provision the 20
million dollars cash that we hold
sits there you know as your backup
um the debt ceiling since there is the
backup
um we have to just show that we have
thought about it and the strategy so
that we know that we can go actually
this is how we can do it
so what is it at the moment
percentage chance what is the 20 million
dollars represent in terms of
a percentage of numbers
um I can't do that off the top of my
head that's at least 40 percent
yeah we cover but we can cover the 40
because that's assuming of course you
have to make the assumption that you
would lose that you wouldn't lose 100 of
your assets
that you would still give funding
um
you could
might be prohibitively expensive though
because you're insuring against the
natural disaster
exactly and that's a lot what
self-insurance in this area sometimes is
but you need to have the Headroom in
your balance though you need to
have the Headroom to do it to borrow
okay just quickly before we move on from
that point the other thing whilst uh we
keep talking about audit having these
requirements the other thing that does
give us a good benefit on is our rating
agency I mean you have to remember that
all these things feed into the rating
assessment and so the one of the reasons
why we have the rating that we do for
our borrowing which does have an impact
on our costs uh is because of all these
things being in place as well yeah
Evelyn you were gonna yeah I was just
thinking that the provision for a
natural disaster would include
um in looking at climate change
provisions and things like that where so
not just
something unexpected like AFA but
something that could force could be
foreseen because we know what the
modeling is telling us about
yeah so where we where we continue to
allow people to love versus where
perhaps
might be a little bit problematic in 20
years time or 30 years time do we have
to start having those conversations and
when and is that one of the things we're
going to reaited against uh don't
believe we'll be audited against that
but we certainly need to be considering
that and um
government policy in that area may not
contribute to the cost of of that coming
forward because I think this is
currently under review
by central government yeah
excuse me yeah thank you I think we'll
finish anyway it is so the next step so
I've been taking notes as I've been
going through
um then Russell and I are going to take
this guidance away and use that as we
put it into
both the strategies as well as passing
it on to the activity managers as they
develop their asset and activity plans
which start coming to you next month I
think it's July you start seeing
activity plan presentations
thank you thank you we're back online
three o'clock Darren
okay you're
thanks for those live stream
it's a good luck shot